so in some sense there is a call to
action within people now you know in any
sort of quest story like The Hobbit
let's say or the Lord of the Rings for
that matter you know the story always
starts with with a call to action right
for some reason or another the little
Hobbit character which by the way is you
you know the hobbits live in this little
protected place and they're not very big
and they're not very smart and they
don't know about the wide world beyond
them where the great forces of good and
evil are at combat and one Hobbit who's
a little bit more adventurous than the
West gets called to act gets called upon
to act and in the Harvard stories it's
usually the wizard who manages it right
so it's a magical figure of some sort
who's extraordinarily wise and
extraordinarily old who might as well be
gone for all intents and purposes who
says you know it's time for you to go
and become a thief well that's what
happens in The Hobbit right this very
weird thing because obviously that's
Frodo right Frodo's The Hobbit in in The
Hobbit and Bilbo's The Hobbit in The
Lord of the Rings IRA no other way
around Bilbo is The Hobbit in The Hobbit
fine Bilbo
okay so Bilbo gets called to action and
he's gonna go he's gonna go find a
dragon
well the dragon is the same thing that
swallowed Joel it's the same story and
the Jew and the dragon has a treasure
which is a weird thing it's like what's
up with dragons right what are they
hoard virgins
that's the st. George story it's a very
very old story or gold and that's weird
behavior for a predatory lizard but
anyways you accept that without any
problem of course the dragon lives
underground in a big mountain that was
excavated by doors and sits on a
treasure it's like we got on we don't
have any problem with that idea
well why fate I mean really you really
believe that and the answer is well well
enough to read the damn book and to make
the I mean how many people went and
watched the Lord of the Rings how many
people and think about it worldwide how
much money did Harry Potter generate you
know I bet you Harry Potter generated
more money than the remaining steel
mills in Britain if you calculated it
across the amount of time since those
stories emerged
right so of course there's a lizard in
predatory lizard and Harry Potter - it's
the thing that skitters around
underneath Hogwarts and turns you to
stone with the glance of the by oh and
does that lizard hoard virgins well
what's the name of the woman that the
girl that he kidnaps Ginny right okay
what's the word Ginny from Virginia
right good good
right and she's harry's first love
interest he rescues her from the damn
snake and he gets paralyzed paralyzed
while he's doing it what rescues Harry
Phoenix right a Phoenix okay so the
basilisk bites Harry and so he's gonna
die the Phoenix comes along who owns the
Phoenix Dumbledore yeah yeah what is the
Phoenix do cries and cries into Harry's
wounds yes but what happens then what
happens to Harry he comes back to life
it's a res death and resurrection story
so the thing that's willing to die and
resurrect is the thing that gets the
virgin from the snake it's like does
that make sense well you think it makes
sense even though you don't really know
why it makes sense and then what happens
to the what happens to the Phoenix after
it does that it burns itself up into in
a puff of flame and is reborn so it's
the story told twice the thing that dies
and is reborn is the thing that conquers
the death serpent end and and rescues
the feminine roughly speaking so it's
not gold in that situation but it
doesn't matter it's the same story it's
always the same story so and when you
don't hear that story like when your
culture isn't providing you with rich
stories of that sort that are derived
directly from your tradition somebody
like an unemployed welfare mother in
Britain has it pop up full-fledged into
her brilliant imagination and lays out
seven books and makes herself more money
than the Queen right right and then you
know it's a Cinderella story it's a
bloody amazing story and then there's
all those books and all those kids learn
to read
because of the books and then there's
all those movies and everybody goes and
sees them and no one notices that they
don't know what the hell they're doing
while they're doing it and it follows
the same old story